hey guys I'm Abby start welcome to
Abby's kitchen today i parted up with my
friends at Wonderful Pistachios who
sponsored this video help Canadians
coast-to-coast elevate their roadtrip
snacking game if you're traveling
anywhere in the summer chances are going
to be stuck in the car for at least a
few hours and you're going to get pretty
hungry
whenever I plan my road trips I stick to
four pieces criteria for my road trip
snacks number one they can't be messy
unless it's not your car and you don't
care about the detailing number two
they've got to be shelf stable because
as we know in Canada our cities are far
away from one another in the great white
north number three they cannot be smelly
because six hours in the car with tuna
or egg salad sandwich not ideal and
number four they've got to be tasty that
one's the most important of course
pistachios check off all the boxes all
in their own so I always spit bag of
them in my car just ready to go
but I also like to switch things up to
elevate my road trip snacking games so
I'm also adding them to an pre favorite
road trip recipes let's do this first up
my matcha energy balls with a great pop
of color and flavor from pistachios into
a food processor I combined some
unsalted shells Wonderful Pistachios
some dates some unclean coconut rolled
oats ground flax seeds nacho powder
coconut oil and dry cranberries puree
until well combined your dates aren't
sticky enough you may want to add a
little bit of maple syrup agave or honey
then roll into a bed a dozen balls and
keep refrigerated until you're ready for
your road trip
next my thai-inspired popcorn pistachio
trail next by mixing it up and adding
sweet chili pistachios we can up our
snacking game with a big pick of flavor
I mixed together some air-popped popcorn
sweet chili wonderful pistachios and
some diced apricots toss with a little
bit of olive oil and sprinkle with some
coconut sugar curry powder ginger lime
zest salt and pepper transfer to two
baggie for snacking on your road trip
finally my pistachio protein oak bites
please provide a satisfying and tasty
crunch to elevate traditional granola
cups first I preheat my oven to 325
degrees Fahrenheit and lightly grease 24
mini muffin tins then in a bowl I
combine some rolled oats freeze dried
berries unsalted shelled pistachios hemp
hearts cinnamon nutmeg and salt in a
saucepan i combined some vanilla protein
powder unsweetened orange juice maple
syrup and coconut oil and stir over
medium heat until begins to bubble and
is very smooth then I just finish it off
with a hit of vanilla pour the protein
powder mixture over the dry ingredients
and stir until everything is well coated
place about two tablespoons into each of
the mini muffin tins and pack it flat
into the bottom of the tin finish it off
with a sprinkle of hemp hearts some
freeze-dried berry crumbs and some
pistachio crumb bake the mixture in your
preheated oven for 15 to 16 minutes
until golden brown and allow the bites
to cool completely
for carefully removing them from the tin
I store my oke bites in an airtight
container for about a week
or I pop them into freezer bags for as
much as three months until I'm ready for
my road trip
thanks again to wonderful two stashes
for sponsoring this video if you like
these recipes be sure to give this video
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
some of your favorite roadtrip snacks
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen happy
road tripping
[Music]